environmental organizations say humans
are to blame for fires devastating the
Amazon our region vital to our planet's
climate more than 74,000 fires have
begun in Brazil this year with roughly
40% in the Amazon area alone Manuel
Bojorquez is on his way to Brazil and
joins us from Miami Manny how do these
fires compare to those in previous years
well good morning scientists are telling
us that there has been an 84% increase
in forest fires this year and many
believe deforestation is partly to blame
but Brazil's leadership argues that some
of the environmental laws protecting the
Amazon could actually be hurting the
Brazilian economy regardless the impact
of these fires could be devastating in
the fight against climate change the
Amazon rainforest the so called lungs of
the world are now filling with smoke the
forest which accounts for an estimated
20% of the Earth's oxygen is burning
earlier this week smoke blanketed South
Paulo Brazil the fires so large they can
even be seen from space
some blazes have been linked to an
increase in deforestation from logging
and the rise of industrial farming and
to understand the environmental impact
this tower allows us to measure health
forests are breathing in and out our
vladimir duthiers visited the amazon
earlier this year where he joined
scientists paulo brando for a view from
above that tree is probably at 3 or 4
tons of carbon that is storing what
happens if these trees are cut down and
that carbon is released into the
atmosphere
this carbon goes into the atmosphere and
contribute to heat trapping in that
field as the fires rage on
so does a political battle Brazilian
President Jair Bowl senado at one point
suggested environmental groups could be
responsible for setting the fires in
retaliation for reduced funding from his
administration a claim he later walked
back
but the groups and protesters blame him
his government is inviting this sort of
destructive behavior in the Amazon
Christians war EA is with the
environmental organisation Amazon watch
the spike in forest fires that were set
are a direct result of the boll Senado
government's undermining of
environmental protections the dry season
in Brazil could last until November
Anthony many thanks